[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ordé dans le Pacifique
au début c'était trop dur de m'y
résoudre
je refusais d'accepter que tu n'étais
plus là
mais j'ai commencé à croire que les
bonjour pouvaient peut-être devenir de
bonnes semaines ou de bons mois j'aborde
le monde avec un cœur ouvert maintenant
[Musique]
Sam c'est un secret pour personne que je
suis follement amoureux d'Emma depuis
quelques années dans la famille à la
famille
allô chérie c'est moi je suis en vie
tu peux pas porter ça à tes
retrouvailles avec ton mari disparu
à quel point je suis désolé d'être parti
je suis fiancée
[Musique]
vous aviez une vie magnifique et ensuite
on croyait tout ce qu'il était mort et
toi tu as trouvé l'amour à nouveau
auprès d'un gars génial peu importe ce
que tu fais tu vas briser le cœur de
quelqu'un
c'était
inutilement verbeux mais assez juste
qu'elle m'aime plus qu'elle la nuit tout
ça c'était incroyablement inapproprié
alors j'arrête tout de suite pour
l'amour du
ciel
est-ce que tu l'aimes ou non elle
devrait être avec la personne qu'elle
aime le plus pas forcément avec la
personne qui l'aime le plus elle je
peux pas alors tu as juste à lui dire
on va quand même pas faire le courses
en peau Marie mon quoi